okay so a lot of you know that my
favorite animated Disney film is
Fantasia of course but if I had to
choose one that told a coherent story
from beginning to end cashing in on the
Disney fairy tale aspect then that would
definitely have to be Beauty and the
Beast
why because everything is done perfect
the main character is perfect the
villain is perfect the romance is
perfect the songs are perfect even the
design of the castle look at that thing
it's like something out of The Haunting
it's just friggin incredible but let's
start at the beginning we get a cleverly
narrated backstory through stained glass
windows telling us the tale about how
the prince who had little to no love in
his heart gets turned into a beast by a
sorcerer after treating her so cool he
was given a magic rose they're slowly
withering away if he can learn how to
fall in love and be loved in return
he'll go back to human
thus we enter Belle she's the oddball of
the neighborhood because she's hot as
hell but she doesn't flaunt it she
doesn't hang out with other women
fawning over men he just reads her books
and doesn't bother anybody which of
course confuses a very gossipy town that
is except for Gaston in any other movie
he'd probably be the hero but here he's
the good-looking villain who has much
more muscle than brains he thinks that
because he's the best-looking man in
town and those the best-looking woman in
town naturally they should get married
he's in that great logic but when Belle
turns him down he swears to get his
bride well that's going on Belle's
father leaves town and comes across an
enchanted castle where the Beast lives
but the Beast says he's trespassing and
throws him in the dungeon where Belle
finds him later she exchanges her life
for his and he lets him go though the
Beast sees this as an opportunity to
finally fall in love he's not very
social in fact he's downright well
beastly I thought I told you to come
down to dinner I'm not hungry
I'll break down the door but through the
help of some very well chosen a very
well paced events the two actually do
start to fall in love with each other
they both slowly start to let down their
defenses and start to see the good in
one another which of course leads to
romance and this action bloodshed magic
all that good stuff people fell in love
with this movie in fact at the time it
was the only anime a film to be
nominated for Best Picture that was
unheard of so why did it hit a chord
with so many people
well first of all it goes back to the
Disney roots but follows all the way
through it's a fairy tale and it knows
that and then totally engulfs itself in
it but as fairy tales go there's a few
twists this time the couple actually has
to take their time to fall in love with
each other they don't just meet and
suddenly they're meant for one another
and the movie is actually very clever at
never saying how long they're together
it could be weeks it could be months so
that way you're allowed to draw your own
conclusions the villain is a much more
realistic villain he doesn't start off
just evil and bad he's actually the town
hero but as he fails to get his way for
longer and longer he turns to more
desperate measures which leads to one of
the more obvious but still pretty
poignant lines he's no monster guest on
you are and then you got Belle Belle is
one of the best animated characters ever
she looks good but she doesn't show off
she's kind though she has her limits
people mock her though she could really
care less and she's just off doing her
own thing I'm giving a what anybody
says on top of it she's looking for
something a little more specific than
most Disney female leads and that's
something greater than herself something
grand something spectacular something
that she can barely comprehend
that's actually pretty deep for a kid's
film it's much better than saying I want
a prince or feed or whatever and it also
works out because it turns out what
she's searching for is in the very last
place you would ever look now there is
an argument that maybe Belle is too
perfect that she's not really that
complex because she doesn't have many
problems or flaws and I'd be lying if I
said I didn't see that she's much more
of a role model the kind of person we
want to be as opposed to the kind of
people we encounter I don't know if it's
still a good role model and the
character still seems exist Abel I don't
see much of a problem I don't really see
the downside and liking her is that
belief in the best of humanity so for me
I really enjoy her she's kind smart it
just does her own thing I should also
talk about the beast - I love the way
this thing is designed whenever I heard
the story of Beauty and the Beast before
this movie came out this is pretty much
what I imagined the beast looked like
very big very werewolf light so I
thought he was awesome I guess if I had
to pick one problem with the movie it
would be the design of the human version
of the beast the animators say that no
matter what they put there the people
would have been happy
because well they fell in love with the
Beast and not this guy I think that's
kind of true but I don't know if you put
in Eric or Aladdin or something I don't
think anyone would complain and plus
people fell in love with the Beast
because you called him beast what's his
real name
did she just keep calling him Beast
after he transformed no it's a nitpick
do I really have to explain what else is
good about this movie you all know the
songs you all know how great the
animation is you all remember these
characters it's just a flawless film as
I get older and older it only gets
better and better it's the pure Disney
fairy tale done to the absolute best I'd
say go see it but let's face it you
already have